[Music]
you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webcast MBA student insights and
military veterans at the GSB my name is
Steve barber I have just finished my MBA
one year here at Stanford I'm joined
today by my fellow veteran classmates
Sara Martin and vineet Rajan we'll be
talking about the student experience at
the GSB today and the experience on
campus as well and we'll try to get to
as many questions of yours as we can if
any questions come up during the webinar
please feel free to use the Q&A box at
the bottom of your screen and towards
the end of the webcast we'll answer
however many we have time for we're not
going to talk too much about the
admissions process today so if you have
any questions on that you can always
consult the website as well as use the
Q&A box and our admissions staff will
try to answer as many of those as they
can so we'll kick it off with some
introductions
we'll start with Sara Sara can you tell
us a little bit about your background
where you're from what you did in the
military why you came to the GSB and
essentially what you're looking to do
after you finish sure Steve so I'm from
the Bay Area so right around Stanford I
went to West Point the US Military
Academy graduated in 2009 and I worked
as a logistics officer and also in
foreign language education and after the
GSB I'm going to go back to the army and
I will teach at West Point and as far as
why I came to the GSB it's a top notch
program and I was particularly
interested in entrepreneurship and it
has a very strong program for that also
thanks Sara how about you Vineet sure so
i'm vineet Rajan I grew up in Maryland
and joined the Marines as an Intel
officer for the last 11 years left the
UK whereas my last duty station and came
to the GSB with my wife Sandhya and our
two children and what I hope to do after
the business school is go into
entrepreneurship or impact investing
outstanding and as I said in the intro
I'm Steve barber I was in the u.s. Navy
for 11 years as an f-18 pilot it came to
the GSB also knowing that it was a top
notch program and hoping to take my
experience in aerospace as a pilot and
transition it over to the business world
I married as well I met my husband Jimmy
and the Navy and I grew up in
okay let's hit the questions the good
part so we'll start out with some of the
questions we've gotten received in
advance so we'll start with how was the
transition from being in the military to
being in school so for me I'd say there
are aspects that I thought went a little
easier than I anticipated
and there aspects that were a little bit
harder than I thought so what was easier
was getting back into the academic
mindset I think you can be confident
that if the GSB selects you for
admission you have what it takes to
really thrive in excel here and it took
a few weeks to remember how to study how
to take notes and what exams feel like
but relatively quickly I got back up on
plane there and remembered how to be a
student and there's so many resources
here at the GSB to help you get to that
point that that process was much
smoother than anticipated take some
people a little longer than others but
you know for me it was relatively smooth
and I was lucky something that was
harder than I anticipated transitioning
from the military to business school is
you know here this many times in the
context of business schools anywhere is
this idea of FOMO fear of missing out
there is so much that goes on at
Stanford that I really found that when I
was in the military we had a mission in
mind and I knew what I was doing for
most of the week we had goals we were
gonna try to achieve and that really
defined a lot of my actions my social
circle was pretty well defined based on
the people that I knew in the military
and it kind of added some structure to
life that I found is a little less
prominent here again there's so much
that's going on with extracurriculars
you can be involved in career research
and treks and just the millions of
offerings that the GSB has that it was
tough at first for me to prioritize and
budget my time to know what was
important to me and what I what I really
wanted to spend the most of my time
doing and getting out of this experience
everyone that I've talked to you has
struggled with this in some way shape or
form so it's very natural but it wasn't
something that I could fully appreciate
until I came here and while it's been
tough at times it's also a really
tremendous strength of this school that
there really are just all these avenues
to explore and develop yourself and
answer questions about who you
what you want to do after you finish up
the GSB another question we had was
about what we're studying or
specializing in the GSB might be a
little bit different from some of the
other schools out there as far as how we
study and specialize in our degree sir
can you talk a little bit about that for
us sure so we have a general MBA program
and so the first year everyone takes
most of the same classes and there is
some there is some opportunity to take
electives and with the journal
foundations you can take classes at
different levels and that was something
actually really appealed to me about the
Stanford program is that I could take
the same classes that everyone as
everyone else but at a level that was
appropriate to me so if I wanted to take
advanced operations I could do that but
if I wanted to take basic finance
because I have a finance background that
made a lot of sense I do I've had I have
had room to take some electives during
my first year for example I was I'm
personally really interested in
healthcare and so I was able to take to
healthcare classes including the
Biodesign Innovation course which is a
nice flagship program and I did a global
study trip there was health care focused
very cool how do you Vanille what are
your thoughts on the on that question
about her where curriculums designed and
how we how we study here I think like
Sarah said the appeal to me coming to
the GSB was the fact that there was a
general management foundation that I
wanted and could achieve here but the
same time it wasn't so prescriptive that
I couldn't take some of the classes that
I wanted to particularly in the winter
or the spring I also did appreciate much
like to Sarah's point that I could take
a class that was right from my
capabilities so I had a little bit of
finance background so I could take a
little more advanced finance classes but
I could go into more basic classes 4d
like that end decisions for example it's
a great point and I was definitely the
base classes for everything that I took
here and like you said I really
appreciated kind of being able to dip my
toe in these new subjects without
feeling overwhelmed because there's so
many people with diverse backgrounds
here that if I was thrown in with all
say finance majors or people who had
worked in say finance or Investment
Banking I probably would've been over my
head Stanford that's the not everyone
comes at the same place when they get
here and really tailors the curriculum
too I find give everyone a great chance
to succeed
absolutely thanks guys all right
we hit a little bit on this when we kind
of did our intros but can you speak in a
little more depth and neat about what
made you decide to apply and ultimately
attend Stanford it's opposed to some of
the other schools you looked at
absolutely so one of the biggest draws
for me was the fact that like I said
gentlemen foundation is I think really
important for those who of us who are
transitioning out of the military
service so I did 11 years in the Marine
Corps and I knew that I needed to like
relearn some of the accounting and
finance that I learned eleven years ago
so that was a big draw for me but I also
was really appreciative the fact that it
wasn't so prescriptive and that I had
some flexibility in my first year and
some of the schools other schools I was
looking at didn't have that flexibility
I really wanted that the number two
reason why I came here was that I'm much
like Sarah I'm very interested in
entrepreneurship but and especially I
focus on social innovation and the GSB
is really known for those two things in
particular so that was a huge draw for
me and then I didn't want to leave the
Marine Corps and then come to a school
and get lost in the huge class size and
so I found that the GSB class size was
about the right level for me where I
could hopefully meet everybody in my
class and actually know their names and
and develop a relationship with them but
not be so small that the network
wouldn't be useful for me decades after
I graduate and the last thing because I
came from the UK as my last duty station
I really wanted something with good
weather if I'm being totally honest my
children like to be outside and it's
really helpful that the weather is
beautiful almost all the year here it's
definitely an important consideration
thank you so we brought up
entrepreneurship you just spoke to it
there Vineet we've had questions about
whether vets can go the entrepreneurial
route so I guess start with you Sarah I
think you've had some experience in this
and this Avenue can you talk to how it's
been for you kind of pursuing
entrepreneurial ventures as a first year
student and looking forward sure I think
actually veterans fall pretty naturally
into an entrepreneurial route they've
they've worked in larger organizations
they can see the limitations of of that
and how how sort of disruptive
alternative ideas can really can really
accomplish a lot and so there's there's
veterans and all sorts of programs I am
in the Biodesign Innovation Program and
I've been working on a medical device
that my team has invented and we are
planning to work at this summer so I'm
just one example of someone who
got into innovative space we have a
classmate Patrick Robinson who's working
on another startup involving computer
vision and and and I guess I'm what
would the how would you phrase what he
does it's like I think he's using
technology to help the criminal justice
system be able to not well even with
that ya know all people to accountable
for certain things but I there's a lot
of opportunities here for
entrepreneurship whether you're a
veteran or not and I think the problem
for the veterans will be is the fact
that you have not had the opportunity to
really think about being entrepreneurial
in the traditional sense while in the
military but now your your your jump
you're dropped into this huge place of
resources where there's so many classes
so many clubs and almost more
importantly there's a lot of people who
are also interested interest in
entrepreneurship so it doesn't end in
the classroom you you often take it
outside of the classroom and spend a lot
of time with their colleagues working on
personal endeavor so I think
entrepreneur
I think veterans are very suited for
entrepreneurship it's just whether
you're interested in it and whether you
want to take a chance while here at the
GSB for sure and then just worth noting
you mentioned Patrick sir he's also a
veteran in our class and our classmate
so rough numbers at least 25% of our
veterans just in our class are doing
something entrepreneurial over there for
summer and possibly beyond you know
gives you a pretty good sense of the
resources that are here for people who
maybe don't have formal experience in
the space but have the the drive and the
hustle to to really do something kind of
world-changing and something I really
and that's me it really stands out about
veterans is the drive in the hustle so
if you have an idea the resources here
are so plentiful so you can be in
venturous studios you can be take lead
launchpad launchpad startup garage bio
design innovation class of the design
school so it's sort of like limitless
opportunities if you've got idea and
drive which a lot of veterans do have
totally and it's not always just if you
have an idea for a product or a company
let's say there's other avenues for
entrepreneurial endeavors like search
funds for example which are something
that veterans also a lot of that we sort
of pioneered the model for at Stanford
have a ton of resources to support those
and that again veterans are ideally
suited for in a lot of circumstances
just because they're they're used to
kind of rotating into a new job every
year or so and learning it quickly and
really excelling at it so yeah glad we
had this kind of discussion on the
details of the stuff that's out there
because it's not just I come to Stanford
because I want to launch a company there
are so many ways to be entrepreneurial
here all of which are incredibly all
support absolutely so something I value
as well another questions come in so the
vets Club is obviously a huge source of
support for us we can talk on like terms
to military members and sort of share
our experiences and get things that may
be the perspective of our classmates
that they haven't been exposed to so we
can kind of build community in that way
but there's so many other clubs here we
talked both of you have alluded to the
Entrepreneurship and tech facing clubs
but there's other professional
organizations and clubs that Stanford
offers that can help people in their
career search or just to find community
so can both of you maybe offer your
perspective on some of the clubs that
have been meaningful to you and your GSB
experience sure sure so I'm one of the
co-presence for the social innovation
Club as I mentioned that I I came here
to the GSB particularly cuz I wanted to
research that that interest of mine of
social innovation and social
entrepreneurship and so social
innovation Club has taken a huge part of
my time but that's because I really I'm
interested in that space and so one of
the other clubs I'm really interested is
is a venture capital Club and so because
I'm doing a venture capital position
this summer the resources that I had not
only from just having the brown bag
lunches with current venture capitalists
but also talking to my peers who've had
experience in event the venture capital
industry has been really helpful for me
to grow and potentially launch career
after the GSB cool how are you sir
awesome so I am in the healthcare Club
and that's been really good for example
just couple weeks ago we did this
awesome trek through the Silicon Valley
we visited a couple different startups
in biotech and also Gilead and it was
really good just have that first-hand
experience you know touring touring
their companies getting to talk to the
CEOs of the startups and then other
folks in in Gilead was really awesome
there's all it's also really helpful for
job postings so the different different
clubs will often share in
ship opportunities and connections with
within that industry healthcare clubs
definitely been really great for that
I'm also Co leading the Adam Smith
Society which is basically a club where
we'd debate free market solutions to
different problems whether it's social
security or healthcare or global pros
and cons of globalization and that's
just kind of a fun club to think kind of
like take a step out of your everyday
life here at the GSB and think about
these much larger issues and so that's
been that's been really fun too to think
about think about that and be involved
with some of those discussions it's also
tied into the Hoover Institute quite a
bit and so we get some really great
speakers that's really cool I know stuff
that I've done I'm involved with GSB
pride which is our LGBT community
organization here on campus that's been
a great source of support and meeting a
lot of great new friends I'm also
involved with this isn't technically an
extracurricular but one of the kind of
flagship programs that the GSB offers is
called the Arbuckle Fellows Program and
what that is is in your second year you
have the opportunity as an MBA to to
lead what's called a squad of six MBA
ones first year students and together in
that squad in this very small intimate
venue you work through case studies and
role plays and discussions and
reflections to really find out what kind
of leader you want to be and as the MBA
- you are essentially owning that
discussion you are helping your squad
members discover what it is that they
maybe didn't know about themselves
helping them find strengths that they
didn't know they had helping them work
on weaknesses that they are aware of and
I know my experience as an MBA one in
squad was tremendously rewarding and I'm
so lucky that now I get the chance to
carry that forward and help kind of
shape just a little piece of the
leadership development that MBAs get
over their two years at the GSB so
something I'm really really looking
forward to how many Arbuckle fellows are
there I think there are about 70 or so
robocco fellows it's a competitive
program you'll typically apply just in
the beginning of your second quarter
here in the winter quarter and you'll
interview you have essays to write and
then ultimately the
select and if you are picked up for it
there's an extensive training that you
go through you take one of Stanford's
signature classes called touchy-feely
there's a lot of information out there
on that I took at this quarter it was
amazing and then when you're serving as
a Nara buccal fellow it's not just the
meetings with the squadmates you're also
having the chance to take two full
quarters worth of classes where you talk
about what's gone on in your squad you
have a one-on-one coaching session
multiple times for the quarter and you
really dissect it down to what
techniques can I use that make me
effective as a leader and what
techniques can I explore in this safe
space that really might be more
effective for me as I go forward and
trying to try and find what's a good fit
for me yeah I'm really really looking
forward to it yeah a questions come in
about a little more on the nose for
military stuff is did GSB students tend
to serve in the reserves can any of you
comment on sort of the reserve reserve
mix and if you were able to incorporate
that into your GSB experience sure I
really thought about joining the
reserves or actively participating the
reserves when I left the Marines about a
year ago I think that's a very personal
decision I like I said I have a family
and so my decision-making process
centered around what I really wanted out
of the reserves and what the costs and
benefits of that experience would be and
for me it just seemed that the
opportunity cost to participate on the
reserves at least at this time would be
too high for my family and from academic
experience here though I will say that
there's a small minority of the veteran
population here that is actively
participating the reserves and there's
plenty of opportunities to do that if
that makes sense for you and so don't be
worried about coming to the GSB and
saying that you have to you won't be
able participate in your your service
you can there's plenty of opportunity to
do that if the question is does that
make sense for you in your current
situation while you are here at the GSB
for those two years I may very well
actively participate the reserves when I
graduate that's a great point and I
think a lot of people find that they
maybe start in the reserves and over the
initial time at the GSB discover that
it's not something that is compatible
with what their priorities are at that
point and that's the beauty of the
reserves in my view is that you can
always transition
out of active duty start with the
reserves and if it's not working at that
point in your life you can transition
out and maybe look to to join back up
later on if that's something that
appeals to you and I know that's been
the case with some of our veteran fellow
veteran community members here at the
GSB one thing I'd want to add the
receive is the fact that as you
transition just make sure that if this
is appropriate for you that you apply
for your reserve Commission so that you
have it should you want to go ahead and
pursue that out you know during your
time at the GSB so make sure you do the
paperwork beforehand so you don't close
that door unnecessarily absolutely it's
much easier to leave the second time
that it is to try and get back in after
fully closing the doors and I don't
think we have any in our class who are
actively actively in the reserves right
now at least veteran members but I know
in classes before people from all
branches of the military have found
units around here that allow them to
drill and balance their GSB obligations
with their military service it can be
done it's a very personal decision that
you really just kind of have to think
long and hard about we talked about the
reserves sorry you're an active-duty how
has it been for you on active duty
balancing kind of this civilian
educational experience with the fact
that you know you're going back to
active duty what do you think you'll
take back to active duty I think is a
good question yeah ties back to why I
came to Stanford and one of the reasons
I came to Stanford was for the ideas
Stanford in the Silicon Valley like
there's there's such a there's such a
different way of thinking that sort of
related to tech and entrepreneurship and
I wanted to be exposed to those ideas
and take them take it back to take it
back to the army getting back to the the
first part of your question you know
what is it like being here on active
duty
I think the some parts of the experience
are a little bit different for me is
that I don't have to I feel like I have
more freedom I know everyone was like
really really thinking about their
summer internships like this is this
gonna like make or break it for Mike for
my career you know it's really super
important and I had I know exactly where
I'm going after the GSB so I think it
took a lot of pressure off of me to just
focus on areas I wanted to explore and
you know and so I've got to do these
from doing that internship in Paris and
finance later on this summer and I'm
I'm also working on this this med tech
company so if it's been it's been good
to just sort of explore the space and
that's something that that I think I
have is an active duty officer versus
other people who are more concerned
about their post USB work it's pretty
cool that you get to take advantage of
not just knowing that you'll return to
active duty and hopefully bring these
ideas to transform the army but that you
have the space to take advantage of all
that the GSP offers in your two years
here and I know are there active duty
veterans who are here at least in our
class right now have found a lot of the
same success you have in that department
absolutely so that's awesome we're gonna
move on now to the audience questions
that have been submitted we'll get to as
many of them as we can first one let's
see this is a great one so two of you
mentioned that you had served for ten
plus years one married with kids do you
find yourself challenged in any
different way by being a little older
than the average student or have any
general advice for someone applying that
is a little more removed from their
college experience
okay I'll jump on this grenade when so I
what I would say that one we have a 30
over 30 group here which is very select
you have to be over 30 years old to be
part of this elite groups elite group at
the GSD and it is heavily influenced by
veterans in all seriousness I think that
having a family definitely affects my
perspective and how I look at the GSB
and what I'm gonna do here I've got two
kids under the age of five and so tea
time with my daughter or wrestling with
her or my son and taking them outside to
play is a big priority for me and that
means that I give up other things like
networking to on certain occasions or a
social event that might be going on so I
think being older and having kids does
affect the way you look at the GSB
experience but it's not forced upon you
it's a decision and a priority that I've
made for my family being older also
gives me the added advantage of just
being able to see things with a
different perspective right and that
doesn't come with age necessarily but it
does come typically with being in the
military for 10 years I think that has
been an advantage the thing that may be
a little bit of a disadvantage if I'm
being totally honest is you know maybe
your experiences differ
but working in the government means that
there was a lot more bureaucracy and a
lot of older technology that I had to
use and coming to the GSB where
everybody is really super tech savvy
means that you might have to like pick
up your tech game on how to collaborate
with other people and how to use Excel
to its fullest capacities as an example
or even powerpoints and so but those
none of those obstacles are
insurmountable but there were some
differences that I that I experienced
when I first got to the GSB yeah I
really second that time from the Silicon
Valley so I thought oh like the tech
thing will be easy and you know coming
here there was all these different modes
of communication whether it was like
Trello whatsapp group me slack I was
like what's slack and and so it took
some it took some getting used to but we
have tons of classmates that that are
super helpful really kind and understand
this stuff so if you're a vet my advice
would be just you know sit down with one
of your classmates and they'll kind of
walk you walk you through it to answer
this question for strengths one of the
strengths I think a lot of veterans have
is that we've we've been in situations
before or just kind of like thrown
throwing it's sort of this baptism by
fire you figure it out and so you know
we figured we figure it out and we
persevere and and it was it was a bit
rough navigating all the jargon the
first quarter actually if I have my one
piece of fun advice that I'm actually
very serious about is to watch the show
Silicon Valley oh yeah watch that show
everything made sense to me I was like
you know yeah cap table term sheets
staff the whole thing b2b it was all
just jargon before but now I've got it
all down
clearly you're ready for that internship
and Finance yeah one thing I will say
just add to that if you're if you've
been in the service for a decade or
longer you probably will be have been if
you're an officer or a major or close to
being a major you know you got to hang
that at the door when you come to the
GSB and just get in the mix with
everybody else if you hold on to your
past so much and what rank you used to
have it might be an impediment for you
to be able to really get the most out of
experience albeit that some of your
classmates might be 24 or 25 but they're
here for a reason and they've got a lot
of value to add so you
sit alongside them and they'll be
teaching you something in the evening
and it would be a sad day if you left
this business school without having
robbed some elbows with some 24 year
olds who really know what they're doing
absolutely yeah awesome thank you guys
here's a question that came in after the
GI Bill and Yellow Ribbon Program
assistance what would be the estimated
financial burden so I can address this
one there's a lot of depths of
complexity to this one so baseline
assumptions going in I am at 100%
eligibility for the Yellow Ribbon
Program in GI Bill if you don't know
what that means make sure to take a look
at the VA website it can be a little
complicated and if there are more
questions we can help you out but if
you're a hundred percent eligibility as
I am and didn't receive any sort of
outside financial aid or fellowships the
level of assistance offered is the same
for everybody at Stanford if they're at
100 percent eligibility for the GI Bill
what that entails is for the 2018
academic year roughly 23 K from the
government with yellow ribbon funds the
way they are that's roughly another 39 K
on top of that so right now you're
looking at I'm always terrified at math
in public but over 60,000 dollars that
will be furnished to everyone who is at
100% yellow ribbon eligibility and with
tuition last year in the neighborhood of
high 60s to low 70s that's a significant
chunk covered by Stanford for people at
full yellow robe ineligibility so very
very helpful for veterans that have
served for a long time and then remember
on top of that that there's also the
housing allowance that's paid to you
every month that up here is on the order
of 36 hundred a month it's fixed to cost
of living for the area so that's a huge
benefit especially if you live out in
town like me and there's also a tuition
a textbook stipend that's paid every
year as well it's about a thousand
dollars so bottom line a significant
amount of financial aid is available to
those who are at 100% yellow ribbon
eligibility and even for those who
aren't there are tons of options that
the GI bill or that the GSB financial
aid office can educate you on that might
be workable for you there's standard
federal loans there's private loans
there's another GI or a VA program
called vocational
that I'm not super smart on but the
bottom line is there a ton of options
out there for financial aid and if you
really want to come to Stanford I would
say that let the finances try to make
that be just one part of the overall
calculation and it may have some more
weight for others than it does for for
some as it does for others but only you
know that so just give it the due
consideration that it deserves
regardless if you were at full
eligibility I can tell you that the GI
Bill is very very helpful attending
Stanford certainly has helped me I just
add one more thing as well as you as you
consider what schools you want to go to
once you get accepted to the many
schools you probably all have applied to
look take an apples-to-apples comparison
and actually compare what you would get
whether you go to another school because
I was actually shocked as I did the
comparison myself as we transition as a
family to the GSB that the GSB after all
the support it provided me was actually
much more affordable than some other
schools that I expected to be more
affordable so it actually worked out to
be economically aligned for me to come
to the GSB and that was to my surprise
so just just do the analysis practice
your pre MBA skills make excel sheet and
adjust for the cost of living and you
might be surprised that the coming to
the GSB is actually the best place to go
awesome got time for just a couple more
questions if we keep her answers pretty
quick so we'll try to get to them here
looking back following your first year
what would you recommend potential
students do to best prepare themselves
prior to returning to school I've got
like two one-sentence answers the first
one would be try to relax a little bit
you'll definitely if you've been picked
to come here you have the skills to
succeed so no need to super overload if
you don't want to if you feel
comfortable kind of doing some prep on
like Excel or something like that you
can do that I would say you don't need
to and then my other quick sentence
advice would be look at the possibility
and see if it's right for you to do a
pre MBA internship there are a lot of
big companies in tech and finance and
consulting that offer veterans specific
opportunities to work in finance or work
in consulting for a summer just to get a
taste of it and that's essentially a
free internship where you can either set
yourself up to go back to that field if
you really like it and you
first MBA one internship or if you don't
like it you've learned a lot and you
have an educated perspective eyes open
about what it means to work there so
that's kind of my advice that I would
give myself looking back on it what do
you all think so my my first I'll just
read or my first piece of advice which
is watch the show Silicon Valley because
everything will make sense and I totally
second you on the excel if you have a
chance and you want to take some of the
more the the axilla or the advanced
classes when you get onto campus I would
encourage I would encourage students or
admits to take a look at the study
materials they give you and try and
brush up on some of these subjects
especially if you want to place into
these on these accelerator higher level
classes that being said if you don't
have the time don't stress out about it
because you'll be fine I didn't I was
really busy leading up to coming here so
I didn't have the time to work on any of
that stuff and so and I was fine
so just do whatever whatever makes sense
for you cool really quickly I would say
that you won't have a ton of time here
to do some deep level thinking about
what you want your life to look like
after the GSB which is a bit surprising
so I would say if you've got the time
and the bandwidth I would definitely
just sit down and talk to your
significant other or your friends and
like kind of design your way through
what you want your life to look like
outside of the GSB so you can hit the
ground running even with the academic
adjustment period being what it is here
recruiting that's how it's pretty
quickly and you won't have a time to
really think about it so if you can
think about it for you comes to GSB be
very helpful and then I think maybe we
have time for one or two more we've got
the high sign perfect alright did you
guys come to the Stanford GSB knowing
exactly what field you wanted to
specialize in and how's your perspective
changed since your time here you want to
start us on a note sure I I did not know
I said that a piece of advice because I
didn't have a time to think about what I
wanted and so my perspective has
certainly changed partially because I
know a lot more about what private
equity looks like now and what
Investment Banking is I didn't know what
any of those things were really before I
came here and I realized some of those
things aren't just for me and for my
family and so I think as you learn more
about each of these possibilities you'll
make the right decision based on your
desires and what your
really capable of doing there are gonna
GST opens a lot of doors but there are
some things that you're just not going
to be able to do because you spent 11
years or 10 years in the service as
compared to your colleagues who did
Investment Banking right out of
undergrad absolutely I would say that
you know veterans that you were all by
the nature of our transition we're
transitioning from one career field to
another so I think there's very much the
expectation that you don't know what you
want to do it's very common I think it's
definitely a really good idea to have
priorities or areas of interest before
you come here so you don't lose focus
but you'll figure it out as you get
exposed to for the smorgasbord of
different different opportunities it's
an excellent work that's an MBA word
right there
so I guess I also didn't know exactly
what I wanted to do I was pretty focused
and where I thought I wanted to end up
in aerospace which is related to my
background that's I'd say probably not
in my experience most veterans end up
doing something completely different
than what they did in the military when
they even go to the business world I'm
kind of tangentially staying in the same
way so I knew where I wanted to end up
but as far as function I had no idea and
frankly still don't I had the
opportunity to do a pre MBA internship
for an aircraft leasing company that
I'll be returning to for half the summer
and then I'll also be working for an
aerospace startup as well for the second
half of my summer so I'm exploring
different functions within one broader
industry and the GSB like far in a way I
would not have had the chance to explore
either of these internships both of
which are really exciting without the
resources and the benefits of being here
in this program so yeah I didn't know
what I want to specialize either in
either and I still don't
hopefully we'll figure it out over the
summer but if you don't it's totally
cool because a lot of people have that
exact same experience and there's a
chance to reinvent yourself 10 different
times at the GSB if you want to you and
if you need to so certainly nothing to
be afraid of
what's this maybe our last one what how
about this how do you think your
military experience helps strengthen
your application and what other
extracurricular activities did you have
that you believed maybe we're an asset
to you as you applied
I'll start on that one I think our
military experience for me it gave me a
lot of really unique and interesting
stories that helped show ways in which I
was able to demonstrate leadership in my
work in the Navy and that is such a
central focus here at the GSB that I
think your average military veteran
often has a huge Bank of those stories
to draw on and I think they can really
strengthen your application make it more
powerful make it about you and show the
various talents you have so just the
kind of unique experience that as a
military member you get that most other
people don't get was huge for me and I
think was an asset to my application how
are you sir yeah I would definitely
second the leadership component I have
the the opportunity to work in two
different very different areas of the
army I was a lead combat missions in
Afghanistan which is and I also worked
at the Defense Language Institute where
I led education initiatives are really a
flagship school for foreign language
education and the types of leadership
you need in both scenarios are so
different and I think that the military
offers you a lot of opportunities to
explore your leadership style to to
figure out how to motivate different
groups of people and we have exposure to
lots of different people so like the
military is kind of this great
geographic representation of the United
States at least in the US military and
we have kind of this this global outward
thinking approach and I think I think
those elements really come out in
veteran applications all right we're
almost out of time so before we head off
Sarah and vineet do you have any final
words of advice for anyone out there
who's thinking about applying for a
Stanford MBA especially if they've
served in the military
we'll start with Sarah you know I would
say absolutely do it if you you can't
catch a fish or hooks not in the water
so try I think one of the things I love
to highlight is the Veterans Club and
the veterans community here I think we
know we're small but mighty we have a
good representation of the different
services and also international vets as
well especially from you have some from
Korea and from Israel especially
and it's so definitely so definitely
apply and then what was the last first
part of your question those basically it
so final words of advice if you're
applying for Stanford MBA especially if
you served in the military yeah awesome
I would I would second serozha thought I
only applied quite frankly because my
wife convinced me to GSB was my number
one choice but I thought I'd never get
into school here and I applied at the
very late at a part of the first season
and I'm here now very grateful for that
and the other thing I would say as a
recommendation is really hone your story
GSB is really about stories and if you
don't have your story really tight about
what makes you special and different
it's gonna be hard to get in here
totally agree on that point and for me
my piece of advice on honing your story
is to start early ideally you'll take
plenty of time to really craft those
essays in particular to give the most
authentic picture of you that you can
and don't write the essays thinking that
you have to appear as this incredibly
like superhero type person be authentic
and be you and show what you've truly
done through your stories and your
experiences that makes you
differentiated and unique and if you
focus more on just being true to
yourself and let that come through I
think you'll find great success and
hopefully find yourself among the next
year's crop of applicants or whenever
you come to the GSB alright thank you so
much to Sara and Vinnie if you'd like
there are a tremendous amount of
resources and points of contact
available for you on the GSB Veterans
Club website just Google that it'll come
right up there's also a contact form out
there if you'd like to try and get in
touch with any member the Veterans Club
we're here as a resource to help you and
if we don't know the answer to a
particular question we can definitely
put you in touch with someone who does
know the answer so with that would like
to say thanks so much for joining us
today it's our absolute pleasure to
speak with you good luck and we hope to
see you all soon thank you
you
[Music]
you